>> Jesse: FOX NEWS ALERT.
MICHAEL COHEN LEARNS HIS FATE.
SENTENCED TO THREE YEARS IN
PRISON AFTER PLEADING GUILTY TO
NUMEROUS CHARGES INCLUDING LYING
TO CONGRESS AND VIOLATING
CAMPAIGN FINANCE LAWS.
LET'S GO TO RICK LEVENTHAL WHO
WAS INSIDE THE COURTROOM EARLIE
EARLIER.
>> JESSE, IT WAS PACKED WITH
MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA, ATTORNEYS
AND FEDERAL AGENTS AND THREE
ROWS OF MICHAEL COHEN'S FAMILY
AND FRIENDS WHO ALL LISTENED
INTENTLY AS HE SPOKE FROM MOST
10 MINUTES BEFORE HE WAS
SENTENCED.
NEAR THE BEGINNING, HE TOLD THE
JUDGE THIS MAY BE HARD TO
BELIEVE BUT TODAY IS ONE OF THE
MOST MEANINGFUL DAYS IN MY LIFE,
THE DAY I GOT MY FREEDOM BACK.
HE SAYS HIS BLIND LOYALTY TO
DONALD TRUMP LED HIM TO CHOOSE A
PATH OF DARKNESS OVER LIGHT,
IGNORING HIS OWN MORAL COMPASS
AND SPENDING SEVERAL YEARS AND
WHAT HE CALLED MENTAL
INCARCERATION.
THE HEARING LASTED JUST OVER AN
HOUR, INCLUDING COHEN'S ATTORNEY
ASKING FOR LENIENCY, SUGGESTING
THAT HIS CLIENT MADE A
REMARKABLE LIFE DECISION TO
COOPERATE WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, OFFERING EVIDENCE
AGAINST THE MOST POWERFUL PERSON
IN THE COUNTRY, SAYING THAT
COHEN WAS A MAN OF INTEGRITY AND
HONEST BUSINESSMAN.
U.S. ATTORNEYS PAINTED A
DIFFERENT PICTURE OF A MAN
FUELED BY GREED AND A LUST FOR
POWER WHO DELIBERATELY AND
WILLFULLY STOLE MILLIONS AND HE
WROTE HIS FATE IN THE ELECTORAL
PROCESS.
THEY SAY TRYING TO INFLUENCE THE
OUTCOME OF THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
JUDGE WILLIAM PAULEY SAID THAT
SOMEWHERE ALONG THE WAY, MICHAEL
COHEN DID LOSE HIS MORAL COMPASS
AND THE MAGNITUDE AND BREADTH OF
MISCONDUCT REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT
DETERRENCE.
THAT DETERRENCE COME AS YOU
MENTION, 36 MONTH IN FEDERAL
PRISON, THROUGH         THREE YA
PRISON, THROUGH         THREE YS
PRISON, THROUGH         THREE YP
PRISON, THROUGH         THREE YR
PRISON, THROUGH         THREE YI
PRISON, THROUGH         THREE YE
PRISON, THROUGH         THREE YD
PAROLE.
RESTITUTION TO THE IRS.
THE FORFEITURE OF A LOAN AT
ABOUT $1,000 IN FINES.
HE CAN SPEND THE HOLIDAYS WITH
HIS FAMILY.
HE WILL TURN HIMSELF IN ON MARCH
HE WILL TURN HIMSELF IN ON MARC6
HE WILL TURN HIMSELF IN ON MARC.
>> Jesse: RICK, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
PRESIDENT TRUMP READY TO FIGHT
BACK IS DEMOCRATS RAMP UP
IMPEACHMENT TALK.
TRUMP TELLING REUTERS "IT'S HARD
TO IMPEACH SOMEBODY WHO HASN'T
DONE ANYTHING WRONG AND WHO HAS
CREATED THE GREATEST ECONOMY IN
THE HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY."
I'M NOT CONCERNED, NO.
I THINK THE PEOPLE WOULD REVOLT
IF THAT HAPPENS."
A KIND OF AGREE, GREG.
ESPECIALLY IF THE IMPEACHMENT IS
ON PARTY LINES AND IF IT'S
SOMETHING REALLY THIN, MAJOR
COLLUSION.
>> Greg: HOLD ON A
SECOND GRADE YOU ARE TELLING ME,
JESSE, THAT YOU AGREE WITH
DONALD TRUMP?
WE NEED ANOTHER BREAKING NEWS.
GET RICK LEVENTHAL BACK YOU.
I AGREE.
TRUMP BEARS RESPONSIBILITY FOR
EMPLOYING COHEN.
THAT'S NOT AGAINST THE LAW TO
EMPLOY A BAD LAWYER WHO MIGHT
HAVE DONE SOMETHING WRONG.
COHEN PLEADING GUILTY IS NOT THE
SAME AS TRUMP PLEADING GUILTY,
THAT COHEN MAY HAVE BROKEN THE
LAW IS NOT THE SAME IS TRUMP
BREAKING THE LAW.
THE MEDIA IS ADDICTED COMPLETELY
TO WHAT IFS NOT WHAT IS OR WHAT
ARES.
THEY CAN'T SEE THE TRUTH.
CAN I TALK ABOUT AVENATTI?
HE HELD A PRESS CONFERENCE
CONDEMNING COHEN.
LET'S SHOW IT.
>> MICHAEL COHEN IS NEITHER A
HERO NOR A PATRIOT.
MICHAEL COHEN WILL REPORT TO
FEDERAL PRISON EXACTLY ONE YEAR
AFTER WE FILED A CASE ON BEHALF
OF STORMY DANIELS.
MICHAEL COHEN WAS SENTENCED
TODAY.
DONALD TRUMP IS NEXT.
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
HE'S THE BEST.
THE POT CALLING THE KETTLE
BLACK.
BUT THAT MIGHT BE RACIST.
>> Jesse: AND HE JUST LOST HIS
FERRARI.
>> Greg: HE DID!
>> Jesse: IN A GREAT PIECE IN
THE DAILY SIGNAL, IT SAYS TRUMPS
EX LAWYER DIDN'T VIOLATE
CAMPAIGN FINANCE LAWS AND
NEITHER DID THE PRESIDENT.
IT'S A METHODICAL LOOK AT
FEDERAL ELECTION COMMISSION, HOW
THEY RULE ON CASES LIKE THIS.
>> Dana: HE WOULD KNOW BECAUSE
HE WAS AN APPOINTEE TO THE
FEDERAL ELECTION COMMISSION.
IT TOOK A LOT TO GET HIM
CONFIRMED, HVS, HE'S A GREAT GU
GUY.
YOU HAVE A CAMPAIGN FINANCE
VIOLATION, AND THAT'S GOING TO
BE ARGUED, AND PRESIDENT TRUMP
SAYING PEOPLE IN THE STREETS
WITH PITCHFORKS.
DO YOU THINK HE'S SENDING A
MESSAGE RIGHT THERE TO HIS
SUPPORTERS?
>> Dana: KNOW, I DO NOT.
I THINK ANYONE WHO -- WHAT WAS
IT?
WHAT RAN AWAY WITH THE SPOON?
>> Greg: I KNOW A FEW PEOPLE
WHO HAVE.
>> Jesse: JUMPED OVER THE
MOON.
>> Dana: SOMETHING ABOUT THE
SPOON.
THEY TOOK IT TOO FAR.
I THINK WHAT HE'S SAYING IT'S
HIS SUPPORTERS, HIS BASE, THE
PEOPLE WHO VOTED FOR HIM WHO
DIDN'T VOTE FOR HIM BECAUSE OF
RUSSIA OR ANY OTHER REASON, THAT
THEY ARE GOING TO SAY LIKE HOW
COULD YOU DO THIS?
WE VOTED FOR HIM.
HE IS THE LEGITIMATE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
WE LOVE WHAT HE'S DOING.
HE DOESN'T MEAN THEY ARE GOING
TO REVOLT AGAINST THE COUNTRY
AND PICK UP WEAPONS AND GO AFTER
PEOPLE.
THAT'S NOT WHAT HE MEANT.
HE JUST MEANT THAT THERE WOULD
BE FRUSTRATION, RIGHT?
BIG TIME.
I ALSO FEEL LIKE ON CAMPAIGN
FINANCE LAWS, IT'S MURKY.
I TALKED WITH THREE DIFFERENT
LAWYERS TODAY.
EVERYONE HAS A DIFFERENT TERM
DICTATION -- INTERPRETATION OF
IT.
MICHAEL COHEN DOESN'T JUST GO TO
JAIL FOR THREE YEARS BECAUSE OF
CAMPAIGN FINANCE VIOLATION.
HE ADMITTED GUILT TO ALL SORTS
THINGS.
HIS OWN DECISIONS, THAT HAD
DEALINGS AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT
HE'S GOING TO JAIL.
>> Jesse: JUAN, DONALD TRUMP,
AS WE DISCUSSED, HE CAN GET
ALONG WITH DEMOCRATS.
HE'S NOT AN IDEOLOGICAL GUY.
DO THE DEMOCRATS RISK SOMETHING
IF THEY GO AND WRITE FROM
JANUARY AND SAY IMPEACH,
IMPEACH, IMPEACH, AND HOLD THE
LINE.
INSTEAD RACK UP SOME BIPARTISAN
COMPROMISES WITH THE PRESIDENT
IN THE NEW CONGRESS AND THE
SENATE AND MAYBE GET SOME BILLS
PASSED.
THEN THEY CAN RUN AND SAY
LISTEN, I GOT THINGS DONE IN
CONGRESS.
>> Juan: THAT'S WHAT HE SAID
LAST NIGHT TO REUTERS.
HE SAID WE CAN GO DOWN TO PATHS.
ONE IS CONSTRUCTIVE AND ONE IS
MORE OF THIS KIND OF
INVESTIGATION STUFF.
BEFORE WE DO THAT, LET ME
QUICKLY SAY THAT IN FACT,
BILL CLINTON HAD A BETTER
ECONOMY THAN DONALD TRUMP AND HE
WAS IMPEACHED.
SO WE'LL SEE.
>> Dana: HIS APPROVAL RATING
ALSO WENT UP.
>> Juan: THAT'S RIGHT.
IT'S NOT A CASE THAT BECAUSE --
>> Jesse: WAIT UNTIL THE TRUMP
ECONOMY REALLY KICKS INTO HIGH
GEAR.
>> Juan: YOU ARE LOOKING
FORWARD.
>> Greg: THERE COULD BE TWO
IMPEACHMENTS.
>> Juan: WAIT A SECOND.
THE SECOND THING IS YOU TRIED TO
SEPARATE COHEN FROM TRUMP.
BUT I BELIEVE THE PROSECUTORS
SAY INDIVIDUAL 1 WHO WE BELIEVED
TO BE PRESIDENT TRUMP, DIRECTED
MICHAEL COHEN.
THE ARGUMENT FROM THE PRESIDENT
WAS THERE WAS NO PAYMENT TO
STORMY DANIELS.
WE WEREN'T PAYING ANYBODY.
THEN THE SECOND THING --
>> Greg: THERE IS STILL NO
CRIME.
>> Juan: YOU WON'T LET ME
FINISH.
THEN HE BLAMES COHEN.
AND THEN HE SAYS --
>> Greg: BAD LAWYER.
>> Dana: IT IS.
>> Juan: THEN THIS DENIAL AND
LIES BY THE PRESIDENT, YOU CAN'T
IGNORE.
>> Greg: NOT COLLUSION.
I AM TELLING YOU THIS IS WHY --
WE SHOULD DO A WHOLE HOUR ON
THIS.
LET'S DO A WHOLE HOUR.
WHO CARES.
>> Juan: DO YOU KNOW WHAT
MUELLER'S PROSECUTOR SAID TODAY
IN COURT?
COHEN WAS HELPFUL TO THEM BY
PROVIDING INFORMATION ABOUT
TRUMP'S CONTACT WITH RUSSIA.
>> Greg: WHAT IF IS NOT WHAT
IS.
>> Morgan: WHAT YOU SAW WITH
COHEN AND THE AMERICAN NEWS
MEDIA, THEY PLED, THEY HAD A
PLEA DEAL.
IT WASN'T LITIGATED IN COURT.
I THINK IF THIS DOES GO BEFORE
CONGRESS, THIS ISN'T SETTLED
LAW.
IT HASN'T BEEN TESTED.
AS DANA SAID, THE PRESIDENT CAN
MAKE A CLEARER ARGUMENT THAT I
WAS DOING SOMETHING TO PROTECT
MY FAMILY.
I SIMILARLY TALKED TO SEVERAL
LAWYERS TODAY AND EVERYONE HAD A
DIFFERENT RESPONSE ON THIS.
IT COMES DOWN TO THE POLITICS.
WHAT DO THE 30 REPUBLICAN
SENATORS THINK IF THE HOUSE AND